[Applaudissements]
quand je vous parle de la plage ou
posent des questions vous me répondez
avec l'accent alors attention premier
drap premier drapeau alors bouder dites
nous pourquoi il faut absolument voir
cette pièce avec l'action chinois parce
que j'ai travaillé toute la nuit
dupuis qui l'appelle c'était drôle avait
boudé wahid épaule s'était mal démarré
mon attention
le deuxième à pau venir voir la pièce on
fait comment alors si tu veux voir la
pièce tu sors métro république
oui mais attention elle est contrôleur
qu après quand tu arrives tu demandes un
du crime un copain à moi il va te poser
une question si tu répondes date 2
invite alors attention aux italiens vous
avez tourné dans de sa mère est ce que
vous auriez est ce que vous pourriez
refaire du cinéma bientôt ils telle
tournée italien ans à l'endroit où
j'étais en italie c'est pandit a dit
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
attention regardez qu'est ce que les
piments au mali alors dans votre
carrière vous avez fait des apparitions
dans les clips d'amel bent les deux
quines vais vous avez johny gagné
beaucoup d'argent pour ça ou pas j'aime
beaucoup gagner argent parce que moi
l'âme au fleix l'alabama fille que j'ai
envoyé ce à quoi alors petite photo
l'adav à m ok c'est drôle la photo la
photo dans martinique jamais j'adore à
timika les images vous le fait alors
vous devez vous pensez quoi de l'équipe
de chroniqueurs de touche pas à mon
poste en affirmant qu ici ou là luna
mois jean baucou 1v audience a justement
parce qu'il est mouillé c'est ça
justement regarder l'action que vous
devez nous faire enfin la voix vous de
nous faire pour la dernière c'est bouder
en parlant d'amour vous allez faire quoi
samedi pour la saint valentin est
normalement là il y à une photo qui
apparaît bien sur wii même une photo il
n'aurait pas la règle était la photo de
gilles verdez donc à cabo verde pour la
saint valentin c'est ça ce gie du zèle
vous êtes tous un sketch
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
m